[Applause]
If we want it to be Christmas The Christmas of
Jesus of Peace let's look at Bethlehem and
fix our gaze on the face of the
child who was born for us and in that
little neighbor people we know each other
that of the children who in every part of the
world have peace
our gaze is filled with the faces of
the Ukrainian brothers and sisters
who live this Christmas in the dark
Alfredo
away from their
coffers due to the destruction caused by the 10
months of war may
the Lord make us ready for
concrete gestures of solidarity to help the
four are suffering and  enlighten the
minds of those who have the power to silence
the weapons and put an immediate end to this
senseless war our time is
experiencing a serious lack of peace
in other regions too in other theaters of
this third world war
let us think of Syria still tormented by
a  conflict that has faded into
the background but has not finished and we think of
the Holy Land where in recent months there has been an
increase in violence and  clashes
with dead and wounded
we implore the Lord that there in the
land that saw him born
dialogue and the search for
mutual trust between Palestinians and
Israelis may resume
Child Jesus support the
Christian communities living throughout the Middle
East
for whom each of those countries  can
experience the beauty of
fraternal coexistence between people belonging to
different faiths help Lebanon in particular
so that it can finally recover
with the support of the
international community and with the strength of the
Brotherhood of solidarity
the light of Christ and men the
reason of the Sahel where the peace
coexistence between peoples and tradition and
upset by discounts and violence
East towards a lasting truce in
Yemen and towards reconciliation in my
amaro and Milan to stop all
bloodshed
inspire and the political authorities and
all people of good will in
the American continent to  work towards
certain pacify tensions pol  and
social issues that affect various countries
I am thinking in particular
of the
Ahitian population who have been suffering for a long
time
On this day
when it is beautiful to gather around
the laden table let us not take our
eyes off the drink Which means
bread box and let us think of the people who
suffer from hunger
especially children while every day
large quantities of food are
wasted and resources are spent
on war weapons in Ukraine has further
aggravated the situation
leaving entire populations at risk
of famine Especially in Afghanistan
and in the countries of the Horn of Africa
every war we know causes hunger  and
exploits food itself as a weapon,
preventing the already suffering population from distributing it
On this day,
learning from the Prince of Peace, let us
all be the first to commit ourselves When
they have political responsibilities so that
food is only an instrument of peace
while we enjoy the joy of being together
with our think of the  families who
are more wounded than life and to those
who in this time
of economic crisis are struggling due
to unemployment and lack the
necessary necessities to live
[Applause]
e benefice degli omnipotentis
e figli e Spirito Santo descenda al
superbonus
[Applause]